deadly coronavirus has now been
discovered inside the United States and
China officials say the virus has killed
at least nine people and infected 473
others millions are wearing masks and
taking other precautions the virus has
reached several other countries in Asia
and is now here in this country in
Washington State
man in his 30s recently returned from
Wuhan that's the epicenter of the
outbreak he is now in isolation at a
hospital in Everett Washington that's
north of Seattle Carter Evans is there
now with more on this story Carter this
has got to be very unsettling so what
can you tell us about the precautions
that doctors are taking well you just
said it they put that man who contracted
the corona virus in isolation here at
Providence Regional Medical Center
they're not releasing his name but what
they're trying to do right now is
retrace his steps to determine who else
might have been exposed to nights ago
the man in his 30s checked into this
hospital hours after he was diagnosed
with the corona virus it was five days
after he arrived back in the u.s. he
contracted the virus while in Wuhan even
though he didn't go to the animal and
seafood market where it originated was
traveling alone socially but surrounded
by others and so that is part of the
work that's being done to identify who
those others in close proximity to him
that would need follow-up education
monitoring education and monitoring are
two of several steps US health officials
and the CDC are taking to stop the
illness in its tracks after determining
it is transmissible from person to
person major airports in Atlanta and
Chicago will be added as screening
centers for passengers arriving from
Wuhan every person coming from that
region will be rerouted through one of
these five airports before they're
allowed into the u.s. this patient is
doing well we will work closely with our
partners at the State Health Department
to continue to ensure that we're taking
what good care of him dr. nancy messier
of the CDC says that even following the
first confirmed US case the global
health community is confident the
overall risk to the public is low
anytime there's emergence of the new
disease it
concerning but in this particular
situation we've been very proactive in
putting in place measures to help
protect the American public
now hospital officials say the man will
likely be in quarantine for the next 36
hours or so just as a precaution once
his symptoms pass he'll be allowed to go
home
Anthony Carter thank you
you